the gym Saga has escalated I don't know
if you've seen those like we talked
about this a little bit yeah yeah so
like more and more people are addressing
like girls filming in the gym and
catching guys creeping on them and then
posting the guys creeping I guess as a
way to retaliate against years of guys
being Creeps in the gym without any
justice right and so now but then people
are calling it up being like just
because a guy walked past you doesn't
mean that he's checking you out yeah
Joey's full dude he'd be checking These
Hoes yeah yeah so this video went viral
but basically it's a girl doing a squat
right and she's filming and then she
gets to the bottom of the squat and she
gets a little bit stuck so
yeah she should have stopped at that rep
right there outside
that was me with Dove on my back
can't she just throw that [__] back yeah
yeah just drop it yeah I think
technically she can I don't know why she
didn't
[Laughter]
Let It Go
see that's what happens
my knee would have been exploded bro
this is athletic honestly they speed up
the video because Let It Go she's
sitting there that long this should be
his own workout really yeah it's
impressive this is its own exercise yeah
silent treatment foreign
and then eventually this girl comes and
helps her out
oh she just didn't want the
embarrassment of dropping the weight I
guess but like the real best ending of
this video is if they just turn the
lights off
close the gym and she's like hello
anyone
but yeah and people are saying oh this
is a case of light be careful what you
wish for
I don't know I'm also like I just feel
like if any guy was there I can't
imagine a guy saw that was like she says
excuse me to a guy at some point he's
got his headphones in he's not paying
attention yeah we don't look at women in
the gym bro yeah no we do but nah we
don't no we do but like we do we look at
people in the gym
let's be honest about this you're not
looking at that you know the thing
that's crazy like when we see
influencers in the wild we'll look we're
looking at them because it looks
influences you said it like influenza
shut the [__] up like we look at them
because they're doing something we see
the tripod like it's just curiosity so
when you see a girl at the gym with a
[__] tripod and you like you can
actually just be curious you might not
just be trying to look at her because
what she's doing and so that was good
yeah you see if it's good they're just
curious that was good just curious yes
yes obviously I'm just a content creator
yeah looking at another content this is
like when a bear goes up to a camper and
he's like sniffing the tent and every
animal expert's like oh he's just
curious he's just sipping yeah he's
genuine and he's [__] biting on the
glass stone he's just curious he just
wants to know he doesn't know what he's
missing yeah
yeah we're all curious you know serious
we just want to know they're curious too
they're looking at us in the footage
yeah I don't know I'm just
what's wrong with looking bro
you can't even look no more you can't
clear you can look you can't leer what
is Lear staring in a [__] creepy way
how long is that
yeah what's the time frame yo just give
us a time frame and then if I go over it
you can test it out that's what I'm
saying but that's what creeps do here
three seconds I was gonna say maybe
that's too short
look it's just this it's one two and
then done two seconds
I'm just second and a half that was long
actually I was [__] with that that timer
but yeah you got a second and a half I
think it also depends on the person yeah
I think for you as a second and a half
I'll be honest for Indians it's probably
shorter we've done that to ourselves
I got to be honest that's on us that's
100 I think depending on where you are I
think there's different people you can
stare for longer yeah black people we
don't get as much time as whites you
don't think so we do a little I think
whites man like where we don't have the
best rep uh I guess that's a good point
then Excuse Me Miss was a hit song all
about Street harassment word facts
that's true we just wanna we just want
to see them smile
Alex stop staring at people after
burning man yes stop staring and smiling
now he just hugs him yes
staring at strangers all over the city
on physical assault
there's a weirdly funny about a girl
filming herself for Instagram like you
can't stare at me at the gym but you are
allowed to stare at that exact same
video honestly that's a great Point
obviously there's two different things
but it is funny to me that someone's
like you just don't they just don't want
to know yeah I don't want to know one
person can't stand here please don't let
it show yeah exactly pause today bro it
is kind of funny like what millions of
people uh you you're shooting this
content at a gym for millions of people
to gawk at you yeah and I do I do get
the frustrations like this is their this
is their version of like getting Justice
when there was no recourse for years or
whatever but it is funny it's like I got
a ring light and I'm filming my ass at
the gym yeah but how often did like
stairs turned into like you didn't pay
for drinks that night
like there's a good side of getting
stared at
[Laughter]
this is from the trainer in the corner
exactly no I I don't know I'm just
trying to say that like
there has to be some level of Engagement
we have to allow some level of
Engagement if you don't want someone to
talk to okay that's fine but there's a
difference between inconvenience and
harassment we need Texas Day Brazil like
Brazilian steakhouse cards oh the green
light red light green light exactly yeah
but the red like green leaves depending
on who you are so you can't even do that
it's like you just listen in order for
your man that you [__] love and
you're gonna have children with and have
a family with in order for them to
approach you you're gonna need to get
approached by a bunch of [__]
they ain't [__] that's just the name of
the game and if nobody approaches you
and guys a lot of women who ain't [__]
to meet the one of course this is how
the world goes around hell yeah we don't
[__] about it all these girls dick down
for years before I found the love of my
life
girls I had to [__] it I didn't love it
yeah
how many pumps I wasted bro you know how
many good boners I wasted my man only
gets about 7 000 good boners in his life
why don't they talk about that oh
they're talking about ovaries huh come
on bro come on bro yeah you said a lot
of sperm we could use that sperm now now
sperm you keep making but hard dick goes
away I'm saying the good sperm though
like one of our trees bro oh these are
fake
Bob is Sam this is listen this is the
name of the game
wake up with a boner now and you're like
oh [__] no how about that no
no
[Music]
I've never had Thursday
oh sick if I wake up with a boner
I'm like who's raping me
somebody's sucking my dick in my sleep
what happens it's like Jumanji what year
is it where am I that's what I think I
think I'm Dreaming I woke up and I'm
like am I still
have a dream right now it's in my pants
no
every time I talk to like every time I
talk to women they don't seem that
concerned about this our guy's annoying
sure can guys be creepy sure 100
especially if it's a [__] late at
night you're walking alone but like in a
public place a guy coming to hit on you
man most girls don't see me matter of
fact most like hot girls complain that
it doesn't happen enough I hear that a
lot from women
so
ugly
all these girls like oh it's so
difficult it's like well
well most beautiful women that you speak
to be like guys never hit on me
yeah y'all look too attainable is the
problem hmm maybe that's why they're
upset because they're looking at these
guys hitting on the back why do you
think you could get me oh so it's an ego
hit and they're blaming it on harassment
but in reality they're they're upset
that a guy that they thought they were
too good for is hitting on them why do
you think you could have me well because
you can't bench 125. or whatever that
was
you know what I mean
the 125 kind of heavy right it's kinda
that's two that's 245s you like one yeah
135 yeah yeah I got that one I'll throw
that [__] up I don't think you do no I
got that you do for one he doesn't bench
oh you can do it no I could do that one
but you got lost a problem yeah long
arms make that [__] difficult also being
weak yeah
I did it twice I did it twice in my life
yeah not now there's no way I believe
you can throw it up no 135 is not that
bad I would rep with 135. yeah but you
don't do it now like that's like muscle
that you have to continue working
yeah but um
but yeah the most I ever did what's the
most you ever mentioned
um
is my guess I think 225. no you've done
more than that you can do more than that
right you can do more than that I would
think you could do more than that that's
two places each side how much is three
plates I didn't I I had like three
fifths I struggled but my friend was
like that's like spotting but I didn't
replace each side that's 315 yeah it's
like 3 15. yeah so then that was that's
crazy that's very different than two
that's way different than extreme that's
a human body bro that's a whole human
thing it's not a human body that's not a
human body that's an offensive line he
cut out 100 pounds that's a person oh
yeah yeah what's wrong with you
laughs
that imagine yeah yeah but that's like a
e that's ego math yeah yeah but I don't
really do plates I like free weights
what do you do with the dumbbells
dumbbells right now I'm up to like 70s
but oh wow I've been I used to be like
hundreds whoa
yeah that's wild yeah I mean remember
when we met Al that man was doing
push-ups with his dick out on IG all the
time bro never let me that's why I need
to wear [__] tights just to keep it
to control the dick yeah not high set
the fly we'll get you some tights